[Music]
one of those bewildering
things that's happened in the past few
years is watching non-profit
organizations completely betray their
core mission
education organizations setting out to
hurt children
environmental organizations promoting
crowding in illegal
immigration which hurts the environment
and of course the watchdog fact checkers
online who about lying but maybe
no turnaround has been more bewildering
than what's happened to the american
civil liberties union
an organization founded to defend civil
liberties
has now decided to attack civil
liberties and strip you of your rights
the aclu in its most latest announcement
tells us the second amendment one of
your civil liberties
is racist quote racism is foundational
to the second amendment and its
inclusion in the bill of rights
is that true we're gonna be literal for
a second and ask coleon noir
he advocates for the second amendment
for a living he's a friend of ours we're
happy to have him on tonight go ahead
norah thank you so much
for coming out so the second amendment
both of us know exactly what's going on
here this is a power grab by the people
in charge
and they want to keep you from defending
yourself but let's just take this
literally for a minute just
for fun because we're literal people is
the second amendment racist
no the second amendment is not racist
now if you want to make the argument
you can make the argument that gun
control is racist and there are concrete
facts that demonstrate
that gun control has a history rooted in
racism but the second amendment in and
of itself
isn't racist for christ's sakes we're
talking about a country
that got its independence by a group of
people coming together with their own
arms to fight off a tyrannical
government
and then as a result of that writing the
second amendment so that we can continue
to protect that country
so the notion that the second amendment
is racist is honestly
nothing but a red herring because if you
can color the second amendment and make
it seem like it's racist
then anybody defending the second
amendment is inherently defending
racism well that's exactly right and
it's i remember i'm
not an american history expert or
anything but i thought that men from
a bunch of northern states took their
own guns south
to end slavery by force they used the
second amendment
to liberate enslaved africans i mean
it's just it's completely it's insane as
you pointed out
honestly the book that the aco is basing
this off of is written by an author
who is legitimately anti-gun she
literally said it
in a conversation with the aclu where
she said she doesn't believe
that the citizens should have
semi-automatic guns which as you and i
both know
that's nearly every gun in the country
so that should tell you everything about
what this is designed to do
all it is is masking a anti-gun
agenda under the cloak of racism and
they know exactly what they're doing and
i just
i just hope that people aren't
continuing to fall for this because
they've been doing it for a long time
now
and personally i think it's kind of
disgusting trying to utilize the racial
past in this country
to to to get the people the very people
who probably need the gun the most
away from the second amendment i just i
just don't understand it and i don't get
it and then the fact that i'm merely on
here talking to you
as one of the most prominent two-way
defenders in the country
as a young black man is also kind of
bewildering to me considering
i i think you're absolutely right and of
course we both know they do it because
it works
and it's kryptonite for a lot of weak
people unfortunately i appreciate your
standing up
for a foundational right that all of us
were born with second amendment colin
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else